Remember that show "Boy Meets World"?
Did you guys watch that?
Of course.
You might remember Mr. Feeny, his teacher.
I loved Mr. Feeny.
Well, his real name, the actor is William Daniels,
and he just turned 95 years old.
(audience cheering)
Happy birthday, Mr. Feeny.
And "People Magazine" talked to William
about his long career and his successful marriage
of 70 years.
Oh!
I know, to actress, Bonnie Bartlett, look at them.
They met back in college and they've shared a life together
acting and living as partners.
And William says their secret is adapting.
He says, "When you hurt each other,
the key to recover, grow, change, and adapt."
And what I loved about this answer is
it wasn't just sugary, right?
It wasn't like laugh or never go to bed angry.
It was about like we change,
and if you love somebody now how they are,
they're gonna change as you live 70 years together.
So can you love them as they grow?
You have to adapt to them.
I thought that was so insightful.
I love this.
Mr. Feeny teaching us again.
(audience clapping)
Thank you, thank you for that advice.
Well, we've gotta take a moment to celebrate
the life and work of an incredible woman.
"CNN" reports, Betty Reid Soskin,
the oldest ranger in the National Park Service,
well, she just retired, Rossy, at the age of 100.
Wow!
That's right.
Betty worked at a park in Richmond, California,
that is dedicated to highlighting the works
of Americans on the home front during World War II,
and Betty was one of those women.
After facing discrimination in the Air Force,
she went on to work for the Boilermakers auxiliary union.
Yeah, and Betty's work shed light
on the diverse group of Americans who supported the war,
but often went unnoticed in the history books.
And you can hear Betty's entire story
in her own words online,
and the info's on our website.
Congratulations, Betty, and thank you
for your incredible service, 100 years.
Like that is an extraordinary life.
Now last, but not least,
it's time for a pick from Drew's Little Yellow Book.
We refresh it on our website every single week.
And today, in honor of Magnolia Week,
it's a Magnolia exclusive.
Okay, so I was just in Waco, Texas.
Yeah.
With, Chip and Jo.
And I, obviously, hit the stores
and did a little shopping while I was there,
and I found this backpack and I'm obsessed with it.
Now I am Mrs. Backpack.
I'm also Mrs. Fanny Pack.
I need a strap-on,
I have to be buckled up and buckled in.
I want hands free, so I'm fanny or back.
I understand, I like to an evenly-distributed weight.
Thank you so much, that's why I like a backpack.
Well, so I found this backpack and I thought the size
and the chicness of the leather just really spoke to me.
It's the Remi backpack, it's made by Raven + Lily,
a fair-trade fashion brand that works
with female-run businesses around the world,
and it's made sustainably with sourced leather.
And it's handcrafted by women who are artisans in Ethiopia.
Really?
So not only is it beautiful,
but it has a beautiful story.
So I wanted to share it with you guys.
Look and we both pull it off so well.
(upbeat music)